j'ai réfléchi au sud qu'on pourrait
donner à marier au premier regard voilà
et j'ai une petite vidéo pour vous en
faites vous saviez beau c'est sûr vous
allez bosser sur deux thèmes que vous
aimez je vais refaire le lancement parce
que vous aimez deux choses dans la vie
la télé et la drague on va pas se mentir
vous avez imaginé ce que donne réveillé
par marie au premier regard avec vous
regardez à jean mi c'est pour vous ces
cadeaux ce soir chassés suite au succès
de l'émission mariée au premier regard
m6 a décidé de décliner le concept en
fonction de la personnalité des
participants si vous aimez l'amour la
romance et le tunning vous allez adorer
mariée au premier regard hu au [ __ ] je
transpire moi j'ai les bonbons qui colle
au papier si pour vous aimez rime avec
un peu niais découvrez marié aux
premières marc bonjour mignonnette mais
bon ce soir que je te salue le nénuphar
m6 va encore plus loin en mélangeant le
mariage et la brocante
grâce à un concept unique au monde marié
à la première cougar alors c'est faux on
attendait qu'il le fasse mais on apprend
que vous avez bossé bossé bas mais il
ajouté